[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
frank son 24 ya me acompaña en el
estudio de rosa pérez mes de rosa vamos
a abrir esta revista de prensa con
información de chile en la región de
atacama en el municipio de tierra
amarilla ha aparecido ya hace una semana
que creo que también muchos lo hemos
visto en las redes sociales un enorme
agujero en el suelo por causas todavía
poco claras a rosa lo aborda tanto la
prensa nacional como la internacional
empezamos entonces un reportaje el medio
español el mundo
el reportaje que lo hizo sebastián fest
buenos días exactamente y si te parece
empezamos con un poco de contexto porque
como bien decías esta noticia salió a la
luz hace una semana cuando precisamente
el 30 de julio una vecino de la ciudad
de 20.000 habitantes de tierra amarilla
situada en la región de atacama en chile
descubrió un enorme agujero a 600 metros
de esta localidad en medio de la
carretera esta imagen que ha circulado
como bien decías por redes sociales y
medios de comunicación alrededor del
mundo no y es que en un primer momento
este agujero tenía 25 metros de diámetro
y se estimaba que tendría unos sesenta y
pico metros de profundidad sin embargo
lo que encontramos ahora en muchísimos
titulares y precisamente ha sido
avanzado por la agencia reuters es que
ya el tamaño del agujero sería de unos
cincuenta metros de diámetro y de unos
doscientos metros de profundidad bien
como como decías el origen todavía está
por esclarecerse sin embargo los y
particularmente el alcalde citado en
este reportaje del mundo cristóbal unida
denuncia a las prácticas ilegales de las
mineras no particularmente en este caso
hablamos de la minera candelaria que
pertenece en un 80% al grupo canadiense
lundin mining y en un 20% al grupo
japonés sumitomo bien a este sería un
poquito el contexto para entender de qué
estamos hablando y cuál es la reacción
de esta población también lo que son los
que de alguna manera hacen esta denuncia
porque también son los que ven afectados
en sus tierras exactamente y la
población por un lado tal y como
expresará alcalde teme que se los trague
la tierra por decirlo directamente no
que se abra este agujero que aparezcan
sus casos nuevos agujeros efectivamente
no y de nuevo lo que decíamos lo que
denuncian es las actividades de las
mineras multinacionales que actúan con
desprecio sobre los impactos ambientales
y también sociales es sobre pues la
región no particularmente el alca dice
las prácticas ilegales de las mineras
así como los problemas de salud de paro
y polución que generan se reflejan en
este agujero no qué es eso mismo un
espejo del entorno social y ambiental de
este pueblo dice hay mucha polución
tenemos muchos enfermos con silicosis
niños y niñas con autismo y la
contaminación que cubre todos los techos
nos secaron nuestro río y lo entubaron
matando a toda la flora y la fauna
silvestre para priorizar el agua para el
trabajo de las minerías agrícolas
entonces pues un poco digamos la
hipótesis no del alcalde que es hijo y
nieto de un minero es decir digamos no
sabe perfectamente de lo que está
hablando dice creemos que lo que sucedió
se debe a que la mina intervino el cauce
del río secando napas subterráneas y
trabajando dentro de ellas hasta que el
suelo colapsó por los movimientos que se
hacen para explotar la mina y el vacío
que se genera debajo del suelo el
orificio que se ve más pequeño digamos
el orificio que hizo debajo pues eso
hizo el vacío y hizo que colapse y por
otro lado insiste en que el orificio se
ve más pequeño desde arriba de lo que es
abajo del todo me imagino también que en
estas poblaciones rosa hay como ustedes
bien lo dijo opiniones divididas por un
lado precisamente la gente que no está
de acuerdo con la minera ilegal pero por
otro lado la gente que realmente vive
eso en esa zona no exactamente es que
esta es una región minera y según
asegura el alcalde ni él ni la mayoría
de los vecinos están en contra de la
mina de la minería dicen que la llevan
en la sangre recordemos además que chile
es el mayor productor de cobre del mundo
simplemente lo que ven con malos ojos de
nuevo es estas actividades de las
multinacionales que al final no pagan a
sus consecuencias en frente a las
autoridades no denuncian los vecinos que
cuando llegan las represalias no llegan
a tiempo ya son al cabo de muchos años
cuando el daño ya está hecho de hecho
explican que en 1993 y en 2013 pasaron
situaciones parecidas pero que nunca
llegaron a digamos investigarse no por
otro lado también denuncian en términos
de impactos sociales que el empleo
tampoco llega a las comunidades que
dicen literalmente no quieren que seamos
testigos de qué eran la ley que sólo muy
pocos jóvenes de los pueblos de
alrededor logran entrar a trabajar en
las multinacionales que sin embargo son
estos pocos jóvenes los que pasan
información de cómo funciona un parte
muy rápidamente rosa que dicen las
autoridades en que imputó se puede
encontrar estas negociaciones entre la
comunidad y las autoridades bien ya este
fin de semana se ha detuvo la actividad
minera se empresa se empezó un proceso
sancionatorio la ministra de minería
marcela hernando visitará la región en
los próximos días y has establecido una
mesa interministerial para ver cómo se
aborda esta situación y simplemente para
terminar se estima que ya dentro de este
agujero cabe el arco de triunfo de parís
seis veces la estatua del cristo
redentor la aguja espacial de seattle o
el monumento a washington para que nos
hagamos una idea del tamaño de este
agujero de la magnitud de este agujero
rosa como siempre muchísimas gracias nos
vemos mañana miércoles con más
información pasamos a saludar nuestro
primer invitado del día